so as we debug the weight loss we look
for energy levels we look for
sleep problems we look for digestion and
then we're at cravings now cravings are
a good indication that there's something
wrong in the body that something missing
and it if you're craving sweets
you're not burning fat
you're burning sugar
so this is a very good indicator that we
need to
fix it okay because when you're actually
burning fat you're not craving anything
so
it just kind of it just tells us that
their diet isn't right yet so if they're
craving sweet that's usually potassium
deficiency we need to have seven to ten
cups of vegetable per day to get rid of
potassium
deficiencies but if they
already are eating potassium enough it
could be just a complete adrenal burnout
mainly the inside of the adrenal and
they need l-tryptophan
to increase the serotonin which is the
pleasure hormone yeah
okay
so
um they're just trying to go trying to
reduce stress and then we have starches
that would be like potato
and pasta
and mac and cheese and all those
wonderful pleasure
foods that people are addicted to that's
a b vitamin deficiency so give them
nutritional yeast
make sure the potassium is in there as
well but they might need
l-tryptophan too to
increase serotonin to give them that
comfort feeling and we might even want
to increase dopamine too by that product
that we talked about before but start
with this right here
now salt if they crave salt then we know
the adrenal is losing salt
and salt buffers the ph and it
transports carbon dioxide so it actually
helps breathing so we're not opposed to
having a consume sea salt as long as
they're doing enough potassium so they
need that salt because it's losing it's
going down so sometimes if they're
deficient in salt they're going to be
tired as well salt's electrolyte and
salt could even be one reason why it
could be cramping that's a rare case but
it can cause a problem with that
so make sure they're if they're working
out a lot and they're sweating well they
need more salt as well
now fat if they crave fatty foods deep
fried foods deep fry catfish with tartar
sauce
fried chicken
i have a history of craving fat not that
i ever give in to my cravings but
that means that the person has a liver
gallbladder bile thing they're not
absorbing the fats of vitamins thereby
they're craving more fat they're never
satisfied so again give them the bile
and that will handle it through the
gallbladder formula
now what about chocolate what if they
crave chocolate
that would be an l tryptophan
thing give them that
and that that will increase serotonin
this means the adrenal is needs more
serotonin because it's burnt out but you
know what magnesium
actually is used to build
l-tryptophan so you could also give the
magnesium two for chocolate cravings
okay but again if you fix the adrenal
you just handled this one
this one
this one and this one
yeah
okay sour if they crave sour or lemon
they have a choline deficiency
and their
choline is needed to make this
neurotransmitter called acetylcholine
and acetylcholine is essential for sleep
and awake cycles and also to support
something called the parasympathetic
nervous system and that's the the system
that helps you sleep
so the best remedy would be to give them
a lot of lemons um and a lot of you can
even give them choline which is actually
a lemon tasting vitamin they'll suck on
it choline and they'll love it
the other thing that you can give them
is
nutritional yeast to increase the
acetylcholine and that will help the b
vitamin
given the b vitamins to make more
acetylcholine but
typically they'll crave sour
to help
consume choline to actually strip off
the liver so people that have a fatty
liver will a lot of times crave sour
because they're trying to naturally eat
foods to dissolve the fat on the liver
now if they crave ice that's iron
deficiency so make sure they're not
anemic or pregnant or
whatever or have a digestive problem but
usually if they're pregnant they'll
crave ice that's an iron deficiency or
they'll crave dirt
so just go outside in the backyard and
give them a teaspoon of dirt okay
caffeine
that is uh you give them uh recommend a
phenol parasitan that's a supplement
they can get if you if they want to come
off caffeine
i just recommend and reduce it i don't
always recommend this but you if you
need it you can give it to them but when
you take
caffeine from chocolate or from tea or
coffee it depletes calcium
and b1 just fyi so just look for those
deficiencies they might show signs of
those deficiencies
alcohol as a substitute i like to give
them kombucha tea
because that actually
helps gives the same texture as beer
and you can also give them that dopa
mu it's called mucuna which is that
in that african
bean
to actually help them come off alcohol
and drugs it's a very good thing because
it stimulates dopamine which is the
pleasure and reward system of the brain
now if they're hungry all the time they
need more bile they need more fat cycle
vitamins because they're not digesting
fats
msg
monosodium glutamate will just increase
potassium the opposing mineral to help
balance that out and then you're just
going to have to educate them
on
what this is what food that it's in and
that this will increase insulin by 300
percent so
the food manufacturing companies
purposely put that in the food to make
you addictive and they're tricking you
and it makes the food taste better than
it really is
so they can get away away with selling
crap
and make it taste good it's like
crap that tastes good crazy okay stress
eater we have a lot of stress eaters out
there so a good remedy would be magnolia
that's a product i think it's called
relora
but just look for a product that says
magnolia and that's kind of like taking
a chill pill and it helps them every
time they go through stress
okay so use this flow chart for cravings
and we'll go on to the next
factor